[Music]
my youtube channel has continued growing
and gaining more subscribers and viewers
every every month every year the number
of comments that I get and try to field
has been going up along with that more
or less proportionally so I've created
this video as part of a series of dr.
Sadler responds videos trying to address
common issues or you know answer
frequently asked questions this one has
to do with people who leave quite long
comments on on my youtube channel and
videos and want to get some sort of
response from me now what do I mean by
quite long if it's a paragraph that's a
long comment comments are usually just
you know a few sentences or so those
usually I can address fairly quickly
sometimes with another one of these
videos but if it gets beyond the
paragraph you've got a lot of text there
and you're looking for me to read it and
then think about it and provide a
response to it I can't always do that I
do want to say before I launch into the
things that somebody ought to keep in
mind when it comes to this that it might
be that some viewers actually don't care
about me responding to it they they
there there's probably some who want me
to actually read what they're saying and
then responds it but I think there's two
other types of common sirs as well one
of these would be people who really want
other people they are commenting on a
popular video and so they're
piggybacking off of the work that I've
been doing and then saying their big
piece and it's not quite spamming but
it's kind of along those lines if it's
not you know if it's not really focused
on the the video and you're not looking
for an engagement with the person who
produced the video it might be something
to think about another thing that people
do some time
is use the video comment area as a way
for them to work out their own sauce and
I would just suggest that that's what a
notebook is for that sort of log is and
if you're really not interested in in my
seeing it responding to it then maybe
that's something that's done somewhere
else right now all the exit I'm going to
address this just then to people who do
want me in fact to to read their
comments and address them and there's a
number of reasons why I can't take care
of each of these you know in an ideal
world I would I would be able to address
every single comment that came my way
but here's here's the thing here's the
bottom line there's 24 hours in the day
I'm getting you know older as is
everybody else there's only a limited
amount of time and I have to be very
prudent given the kind of work that I do
about where I'm going to commit my time
if I were to try to address every single
comment at length that I get that would
really cut into the time that I have
available for producing content for you
know continuing the to build the channel
and the other things that I do as well
you know pretty busy guide I you know
work for stoicism today is the editor I
you know I have corporate clients I have
you know professional and personal
clients that I do counseling with and
tutorials and all this other stuff as
well I'm building online classes so I
don't have the luxury of devoting
unlimited time to you know big block of
text first of all trying to read it and
figure out what's being said and then
see whether I have something you know
intelligent to say in response so that's
one factor right there and I think a lot
of people who write these long as
comments may not they may not realize
that they may not think about that
that's okay now you know if you're in
that case now now you know
I should someday probably do a breakdown
of what my days typically look like
another thing that I think comes up
quite a bit is people will sometimes
right along ish comment several
paragraphs and it'll have a number of
different questions in the midst of it
or a number of things that they want me
to respond to and if you're writing that
sort of thing the best thing that you
could do is to signal to me which one of
them because i'm not going to address
all of them but which one of them you
would most want me to try to tackle that
might be the thing to put at the very
start you know or an Asterix a this is
the one thing I realized that I put a
lot of other stuff here but there's the
one thing dr. Sadler but if you do
respond to I'd like a response on this
and I will try to honor that as much as
I can this leads me to the third factor
that I think people need to keep in mind
if you're making a lot of rather
sweeping or questionable assumptions or
assertions and then asking a question
after that I might not be able to
adequately address your question because
I'm like we'll look it's a non-starter I
don't buy all this other stuff that
you're you're saying or or assuming and
so I can't really address this it's not
going to work and that happens quite
often you know particularly when we're
dealing with philosophy because people
might have read an intro to philosophy
text or watched a video about a
particular thinker or school and now
they going to believe that they know
what that person is their position or
their assumptions are and they go off of
that and I'll be a look step that's just
not right or sometimes people sometimes
there can be a language barrier when
people are using words and rather
non-standard ways so you know I can't
really take the time to try to clarify
with each
personal what do you mean by this what
do you mean by this what do you mean by
this it's just not you know feasible for
me and there is going to be some things
where I look at if you're going to hold
a particular position that's you know
particularly polemical in fact those
four examples it's a video about John
Paul Sartre and you decide that look
some sarcasm easeus he might he must be
wrong and then you proceed from that
base if there's not much for us to say
right and I'm myself not not you know
committed to search philosophy but it on
videos I presenting is you know
charitably for that sponsor responses
I'm not going to say well okay so he's
an atheist so he's automatically wrong
is the good critics of start don't say
that sort of thing that's not good
philosophical critique and we could go
the other way to you know when people
say oh god real Marcel he was a
Christian so he must be stupid you know
I can't buy into anything well that's
you not being able to buy into
everything and so if you light right a
big long paragraph full of stuff like
that I don't really want to have that
conversation so you know what are what
are the sort of best practices probably
the best thing is don't write really
really long as to begin with or if you
do make sure that your clarifying for me
what it is that you would really really
really like me to focus in on and i'll
see if i could get to it i can't promise
and i will get to everything the other
thing that I will say is that if you
really want to you know or feel like
you're entitled to make demands on my
time in that respect if you want me to
spend half an hour to an hour trying to
figure out what it is that you're trying
to make sense of in the video and then
to respond to it that's the sort of
thing that we do in tutorial services
that's the sort of thing where you would
want to book my time as a working
professional and hire me at least for
that you know our period i offer rapes
you know
that are a bit lower if you if you book
five hours or 10 hours but that's that's
where people who really want to study in
a concerted way with with me but if you
know if there's something that you not
clear in nature or Hagel or Aristotle or
epictetus and you really really really
want clarification about it maybe the
comment section is not the best place to
try to get that if what you've got is a
complex systematic question that's the
sort of thing that we hash out
one-on-one where I bring to bear my you
know at this point more than 25 years of
experience tutoring and more than 20
years of experience teaching and help
you up so all of that said I don't want
to discourage anybody from commenting
but if i don't respond to the longest
comment or if you see this video there's
spots now you know the reason
[Music]